[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique sur
france 3 bourgogne on peut le considérer
comme un héritage du passé mais le
patrimoine avec ses monuments petits et
grands fait partie de notre bien commun
des oeuvres et des édifices qu'il faut
protéger et préserver mais ça n'est pas
si simple et souvent ça coûte cher pour
ouvrir des pistes
emmanuel macron a confié une mission à
l'animateur stéphane bern une liste de
250 sites en péril a été établi douze
monuments de bourgogne en font partie
parmi les idées proposées pour financer
leur restauration un loto du patrimoine
en septembre prochain
au-delà de cette grande opération notre
patrimoine est il réellement danger de
quel monument parle-t-on doit-on
consacrer autant d'argent pour leur
sauvegarde
et en quoi est ce si important on en
débat ce matin avec mes invités guy bdl
bonjour oui donc je vous êtes délégué
régional de la fondation du patrimoine à
ce qu'on peut résumer en quelques mots
la mission de la fondation du
verdissement de fondation créée par
l'état en 1996 mais fondation de droit
privé donc constitué d'abord de
bénévoles on et 26 bénévoles en
bourgogne franche comté
quelques salariés puisque nous sommes ou
dit tabler audités par la cour des
comptes et nous devons gérer au centime
près l'argent qui nous est confiée puis
enfin un grand partenariat avec la drac
qui sont nos amis et qui participent à
la vie la validation technique des
projets direction régionale des affaires
culturelles les représentants de l'état
du ministère de la culture soyons précis
en région que nous avions d'ailleurs
invité pour cette émission mais qui
n'ont pu être avec nous ce dimanche
matin en direct
et puis vous guider d'elle avec la
fondation du patrimoine vous accompagner
cette mission de stéphane bern dont on
parlera dans cette émission
dans un instant corinne molina bonjour
vous êtes directrice de la fédération
remparts bourgogne franche comté même
question avec les associations que vous
fédérez quel est votre action remparts
est un mouvement national à nous
regroupons 170 associations sur la
france et sur cette grande région nous
regroupons 40 associations
l'idée de remparts c'est un village qui
se regroupent autour d'un patrimoine et
qui souhaite restaurer ce patrimoine
pour le réutiliser donc aujourd'hui nous
notre coeur de métier ce sont les
chantiers de bénévoles internationaux
donc des jeunes qui viennent du monde
entier passer des vacances utiles vivre
une expérience unique qui porte sur la
transmission d'un savoir faire et sur le
vivre ensemble entre nos bénévoles merci
on y reviendra bien sûr patrick
giraudeau bonjour bonjour vous êtes
président de l'association les clés de
rochefort à asnières en montagne c'est
en côte-d'or et vous vous battez vous
pour préserver le château de rochefort
on en a déjà parlé sur cette antenne de
france 3 bourgogne cette année d'un
édifice renaissance très abîmée par le
temps
pourquoi une association pour s'occuper
de ce château dans cette petite commune
puisque château une qualité à la fois
historique et architectural et puis ce
château il ya aussi un charme qui a
séduit les adhérents de cette
association est donc depuis 2002 on ne
devra à sa sauvegarde et à sa
sécurisation pour l'ouvrir à un public
et lui faire découvrir la qualité de cet
édifice avec déjà beaucoup d'opérations
sur lesquels on reviendra évidemment et
puis aussi une inscription sur cette
fameuse liste donc présenté par stéphane
bern
merci à tous les trois d'avoir accepté
cette invitation en direct ce dimanche
et vous qui nous regarde et vous pouvez
bien sûr commenter cette émission sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag dit
mme paul bourgogne alanguie mais là une
question toute simple pour commencer
quand on parle de patrimoine on parle de
quoi exactement de presque tout ce qu'on
veut ça peut être une voiture ça fait
une péniche à saint-jean-de-losne ça
peut être un avion non bien sûr ça peut
être une église l'avoir donc le
patrimoine c'est souvent quelque chose
fait exprès dire quelque chose qui a une
histoire
on redonne une histoire en
reconstruisant en restaurant cet édifice
à bp un entendu ce qui est souhaitable
et lui redonner une autre histoire
ensuite une histoire pour l'attractivité
de la région
corinne royer là vous avez la même
définition c'est à dire que tout peut en
quelque sorte être patrimoine on ne
parle pas que des châteaux ou des
chapelles quoi oui tout à fait et nous
on parle du champ des patrimoines
patrimoine bâti principalement mais
également des sites archéologiques
je pense à une serre 19e qui est dans
une petite commune rurale de saône et
loire
à mon sens il n'y a pas que que du
patrimoine dit majeur ou important mais
il ya surtout le patrimoine vernaculaire
donne aux communes rurales où là où
effectivement ça en mérite de s'y
intéresser
c'est ça parce que ce qui fait
l'actualité en ce moment c'est
évidemment cette liste de stéphane bern
sur laquelle on va revenir mais il ya
derrière en arrière fond l'idée que
c'est le patrimoine aussi du rural qu'il
faut préserver parce que on sait bien
que les bâtiments de paris et de la
région parisienne sont bien entretenues
dit bébel oui certainement mais il ya un
autre sujet qui s'appelle l'attractivité
des centres bourgs
si vous voulez la désertification des
centres bourgs et donc le mot re le mot
rural on essaye de l'élargir et plutôt
de parler de patrimoine et quelque chose
qui valorise une commune qu'elles soient
grandes ou petites
on fait une opération par exemple à sens
où il ya un coeur historique
pardon vous faire un ensemble de
restaurations pour redonner de la valeur
au centre ville de sens donc pour ça le
patrimoine c'est pas uniquement rural et
on essaye d'y donner une connotation
beaucoup plus large que le mot rurale
parce qu'on est au service du patrimoine
français vous avez l'impression patrick
géraudot que ce patrimoine rural ou en
tous les cas en région dans les centres
bourgs effectivement mais aussi vraiment
dans la ruralité il a été un peu oublié
ces dernières années
oubliée je dirais peut-être pas mais
vous vous êtes senti un peu seul par
moments dans votre combat
non non jamais non s'est jamais sentie
seule par contre on sait très bien on va
en parler tout à l'heure que la
restauration de ce patrimoine
coûte très cher il ya des communes qui
n'est communes ou des collectivités qui
ne peuvent pas assurer la globalité des
financements c'est le gros problème
c'est le gros problème et on va y venir
bien sûr mais peut-être un mot sur
comment ces bâtiments en sont arrivés là
commune molina vous avec vos
associations vous vous vous organisez
des chantiers de restauration vous
retrouver parfois des bâtiments qui sont
très dégradées c'est quoi c'est
uniquement le temps qui a fait son
oeuvre pas seulement le temps les hommes
qui ont oublié nous un rempart on a
l'habitude de dire que lorsqu'on vit
dans un village une ville on est
tellement habitué à avoir dans son décor
ce patrimoine qui est là que quelques
parents l'oubli on sait que le dijonnais
n'est jamais allé visiter la tour de
mare par exemple et que l'on connaît
mieux le patrimoine hors de son
territoire que le sien il ya un bon
profit des patrons même quand on part en
vacances et ça et armand il faut qu'on
se le réapproprient ce patrimoine c'est
ça c'est le patrimoine oublié
oui c'est vrai qu'il se serait jeté dans
les trente glorieuses des trente
glorieuses on a vécu le moderne le béton
le parpaing etc qui a fait que pendant
un moment le bâtiment siens n'avaient pu
une réelle valeur et puis depuis
quelques années est en trop des
associations comme maisons paysannes de
france
la création de la fondation du
patrimoine on s'est dit que ce
patrimoine avait de la valeur et qu'il
fallait le sauvegarder le protéger
si vous allez dans la france entière
maintenant les pavillons moderne se
ressemblent de l'alsace à la normandie
etc
alors que on a quelque chose qui à
chaque fois personnalisé qui contient
une histoire et en plus des savoir-faire
qu'il faut faire perdurer
donc je crois que vous parliez à
l'instant des centres bourgs patrick
giraudeau disait souvent ce sont des
petites communes qui ont à gérer ce
patrimoine là et c'est vrai soixante
pour cent des propriétaires de la liste
dressée par stéphane bern sont des
collectivités locales parfois des très
petites communes pour lesquelles c'est
souvent très lourd c'est un budget
colossal
et puis peut-être aussi ça n'est plus
forcément une priorité parce que bien
dans le dans le pack le pack de la
mairie il ya l'école il ya la voirie il
ya tout un tas de choses dont vous êtes
confrontés dès fois ces situations là
oui bien sûr on est confronté à ces
situations c'est pour ça qu'on
intervient auprès des communes en
particulier
on essaye de créer ou de faire avoir
avec les communes des associations
puisque c'est une clé aussi du mécénat
populaire si vous voulez que l'on met en
oeuvre avec les communes donc donner de
l'animation créer des associations et
tout ça permet aussi d'aider au
financement faut rappeler aussi que
quand on lance un projet dans une petite
commune il faut savoir que la moitié des
donatrices et donateurs si on les
sollicite viennent de la région
parisienne avec mais non mais vraiment
pourquoi écouter moi-même vosgien j'ai
migré à un moment donné dans la région
parisienne
donc on a tous une âme quelque part même
si on n'y est plus et quand on sollicite
cet homme de quelque part est bien bien
entendu on a envie de faire quelque
chose parce que notre église notre
l'avoir c'est quand même quelque chose
de caractéristiques de là où nous venons
mais il faut un moment donné c'est pas
si et corine moinat vous avez eu huit
experts et une volonté politique aussi
au delà de la question du budget avec
une question évidemment très importante
même prioritaire pour les petites
communes et en même temps il ya une
volonté politique puisque effectivement
il ya souvent d'autres priorités
peut-être même d'ailleurs sur le plan
électoral on peut le dire
il faut 6 e
le conseil municipal d'une petite
commune n'a pas envie de restaurer un
patrimoine peu importe il ya un groupe
un collectif de citoyens qui se créent
sous forme associative et qui peut
prendre à charge en fait la restauration
et la mise en valeur de ce patrimoine et
après de toute façon les et les élus
adhérents au projet parce que le
patrimoine est fédérateur le patrimoine
transmet le patrimoine construit et le
patrimoine est intergénérationnel en
fait et le patrimoine permet par exemple
de mettre en lien les établissements
scolaires du territoire avec son
patrimoine pour permettre aux enfants de
se réapproprier cette notion pas de
moyens et de se construire en fait en
tant que citoyen c'est important parce
qu'on n'est pas uniquement dans la
restauration de vieilles pierres même si
c'est important on est surtout dans la
construction de l'homme c'est surtout ça
qui est intéressant
restauration pierre vacances et pâle
c'est pas que ça c'est pas que ça l'est
mais aussi la part oui mais c'était
presque la partie émergée de l'iceberg
parce qu'on se rassure une identité
oui et recréer une histoire à la suite
oui c'est ça que vous lisiez tout à
l'accord et puis garder quelque chose
qui est caractéristique de nos campagnes
mais ça peut être aussi des villes et
auquel on tient et qui permettent de
soutenir je pense qu'on y parle là on en
parlera de l'attractivité du territoire
et assurer l'attractivité du territoire
c'est de l'économie
et oui pour sa patrie du chantre fr
chaque fan mais qui rapportent aussi
avec cheikh patrimoine en fin de compte
le patrimoine c'est un vrai vecteur
d'attractivité l'insoumis on va y
revenir
voilà parmi les sites retenus dans la
liste de stéphane bern il y a les forges
de buffon c'est en côte d'or je vous
propose d'aller les visiter et on en
repart tout de suite après
un domaine à l'ambiance bucolique
pourtant c'est bien d'un ancien site
industriel dont il s'agit créé en 1768
les forges employait plus de 300
ouvriers et produisait près de 400
tonnes de fer par an pour les
propriétaires des lieux un patrimoine
imposant et difficiles à entretenir les
travaux ne ment pas l'image de cette
grande roue elle permettait d'activer
les soufflets attisant le feu du haut
fourneau
c'est tout un ensemble qui était
admirablement bien constituer ya trente
ans mais au bout de 30 ans voire 35 ans
il est indispensable de faire des
travaux
la roue est bloqué la passerelle sur
laquelle on pouvait y admirer a disparu
à la suite d'une inondation et donc il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de travaux qui
s'élève au minimum à 150000 euros
autre élément en péril le barrage sur
l'art mans sont le vannage régulant le
débit de l'eau dans la forge est hors
service sur le domaine près de 500000
euros serait nécessaire qu'en faire face
aux travaux les plus urgents
nous sommes colossales pour ces
particuliers comme on n'a pas de fortune
personnelle une retraite de
fonctionnaires ne même pas de restaurer
nous avons des visiteurs mais les
visiteurs nous permettent uniquement
depuis le personnel et d'entretenir la
propriété mais pas les gros travaux
comme 249 autres sites en france les
forges de buffon pourrait bénéficier des
gains de la loterie du patrimoine une
bonne nouvelle pour la famille
vestiaires propriétaire des lieux depuis
six générations
ça pourrait énormément nous aider mais
il faut pas trop rêver non plus voilà on
n'est pas tout seul
derniers préparatifs
juste avant la réouverture du site au
public le patrimoine et
une histoire de famille et tout le monde
mais n'a mal une histoire de famille les
forges de buffon guy bébel là on est
chez les propriétaires privés on parlait
des petites collectivités il ya aussi
des propriétaires privés qui gère des
biens du patrimoine des héritages
souvent des lieux de famille quelquefois
comme on l'a vu là on les aide de la
même façon sans distinction ou bien il
ya des contraintes supplémentaires
c'est plus compliqué est ce qu'il faut
mettre de l'argent public dans des
propriétés privées
écoutez je pense que ça fait beaucoup
mieux s'aperçoit non non ça fait
beaucoup de questions mais en même temps
on s'aperçoit de plus en plus que des
propriétés privées qui ont une histoire
écouter les forges de buffon le système
hydraulique des forces de défenses et
c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel qui
n'appartient pas d'ailleurs qu'à ses
propriétaires privés et si je puis dire
il nous appartient à toutes et à tous et
préserver ce patrimoine et est important
et on se retrouve maintenant avec des
propriétaires privés qu'il faut aider
sinon ils ne seront pas à supporter la
charge nécessaire je crois que c'est ce
qui vous a été indiqué
donc c'est pour ça que j'étais très
content de construire ce projet pour les
projets stéphane bern avec l'architecte
dominique jouffroy et voilà pile à terre
parce que je crois que c'est important
la différence son nom bien sûr les
process sont différentes même image et
l'appel au mécénat l'appel au soutien
devient indispensable pour un certain
nombre de propriétaires
nous ne sommes plus à une époque où la
fois on épousé la fille d'un banquier et
ça permettait d'entretenir la propriété
excusez moi oui c'est un peu dépassé
effectivement la commune molina ça vous
arrive aussi d'organiser des chantiers
sur des propriétés privées non parents
pas
grands parents nous ne travaillons que
sur des biens qui appartiennent à des
communes ou lorsque l'on intervient
comme par exemple l'exemple du château
de rochefort on signe un bail
emphytéotique entre le propriétaire et
l'association ce qu'en france pour
qu'une association et des financements
publics il faut qu'elles soient maîtres
d'ouvragé donc il ya transfert de
maîtrise d'ouvragé entre le propriétaire
et cette association mais parce que vous
à patrick giraudeau pour le château de
rochefort vous à vous étiez confronté
finalement à un propriétaire qui ne
pouvait pas ou ne voulaient pas ne
souhaitait pas restauré son château on
avait un bail emphytéotique comme
corinne viens de dire début 2010 est le
propriétaire nous a proposé d'acheter le
château ça s'est finalisé en décembre
donc depuis la fin d'année 2010 est en
est devenue propriétaire
alors on va voir quelques images du
château qu'on avait réalisé en 2015
depuis il ya déjà eu quelques travaux
mais pourquoi est ce qu'à un moment
donné il ya une association qui secret
comme ça pour autour de autour d'un
monument
même si c'est un trait une très belle
bâtisse de la renaissance qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est ce qui motive les gens de votre
association
corinne molina le sait parce qu'elles
travaillent avec vous savard et rick
était pas encore arrivé dans la société
créée en 2002 je pense que là ce sont
les habitants de cette petite commune
qui sont intéressés à ce site
sans doute parce que le propriétaire
n'avait pas les moyens ou pas l'envi en
tous les cas de restaurer et de mettre
en valeur son château donc c'est une
fois tu ce rempart des marques comme ça
c'est souvent parce que effectivement au
soit la commune soit le propriétaire n'a
ni les moyens ni l'envié et alors vous
n'avez pas attendu
stéphane bern si j'ose dire même si on
est très content qu'il fasse cette
opération n'avait pas tendues stéphane
bern pour vous occuper de ce château
puisque en 2015 les images qu'on vient
de voir maintenant vous nous avez amené
d'autres photos parce que ça a
évidemment évolué mais les images qu'on
vient de voir bien vous lanciez une
opération de crowdfunding pour financer
de la restauration du château par la
totalité évidemment ce que c'est assez
colossal avance une fi nancement
participatif pour recouvrir je sais pas
si on la voit la tour nord qui est la
tour principale du château
on va la voir vous voit sur l'image là
on voit le voilà pour sauvegarder cette
voûte qui malheureusement était
infiltré par des par l'eau est donc
menacée de voix la voix l'on voit le
l'état de la toiture est à la hauteur et
on voit surtout la couverture qui a été
brisée en 2015 à la suite de cette
opération de financement participatif
alors vous n'êtes pas les seuls
évidemment à vous engager pour le
patrimoine on peut se demander si les
français s'intéressent à ça alors qu'il
ya d'autres problèmes
la lutte contre terrorisme évidemment
les questions d'emploi etc
c'est vrai que et bien je vous propose
de regarder ce sondage il date un tout
petit peu parce qu'il a été réalisé en
2016 c'est une étude opinionway qui dit
que 67% des français estiment qu'il faut
s'occuper du patrimoine que c'est urgent
de s'en occuper et 55% des français se
disent prêts à y consacrer du temps
alors ça c'est bien lui consacrer du
temps c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
est ce que est ce que ce serait comme
une sorte de conscience patrimoniale est
ce qu'on peut aller jusque là oû molina
oui on le voit bien lors des journées
européennes du patrimoine
tous les sites qui sont ouverts au
public sont pris d'assaut fin on voit
bien que le français s'intéressent à son
patrimoine
encore une fois c'est installer un
fédérateur en fait entre entre les
hommes
ça permet de transmettre ça permet de
construire ça permette d'être actif et
le patrimoine géré nous ne sommes que
des passants le patrimoine restera après
après nouveau fait ça qui est
intéressant
libé d'elle vous confirmer car il ya cet
intérêt cet engouement pour le
patrimoine d'intérêt pour un intérêt
pour l'histoire on a intérêt pour des
choses belles parce que quand même
quelque part on essaie de rendre belle
un certain nombre de choses d'édifices
qui tombé en désuétude
il ya de la pédagogie autour de sappi
rappelons aussi que le patrimoine tous
les travaux que non que l'on fait c'est
de l'activité
donc c'est de la production sur des
savoir-faire qu'on a besoin de faire
perdurer des artisans où ils sont à
peine moins en moins nombreux à est
derrière s'est développée comme je le
disais tout à l'heure de l'attractivité
donc j'ai eu envie d emploi il ya de
l'économie de l'emploi et vous voyez
bien que chaque fois qu'il ya de
l'emploi il ya un certain nombre de
cotisations sociales qui permettent de
financer autre chose dont vous voyez
c'est un cercle vertueux c'est un cercle
d'économie et qui va très bien aussi
avec les technologies modernes
alors on va parler technologies modernes
mais un tout petit peu d'industries je
vous propose
de découvrir du patrimoine industriel
plus récents avec le hangar de
l'aérodrome de thise c'est près de
besançon dans le doubs
regardez qui sont aussi donc dans la
liste dressée par stéphane bern
il a fêté ses 80 ans l'an dernier avec
ses sept mille mètres carrés de tôle et
sa structure de type eiffel le hangar de
l'aérodrome de thise est unique en
france
classé monument historique en 2007
il est aujourd'hui recouverts de rouille
[Musique]
le risque c'est que des tôles s'envole
en quad provence à fès en cas de neige
et c'est donc sur un frein dans
l'activité ce qui serait dommage pour
sauver cet édifice le coût de la
rénovation s'élève à 2,5 millions
d'euros
état et collectivités devraient financer
ce projet qui pourrait être boostée par
une enveloppe supplémentaire de 300000
euros coup de pouce ou non les travaux
devraient avoir lieu cet été
ce qui n'empêche pas le maire d'espérer
on trouve dans la liste des des dossiers
qui ont été retenus des fontaines des
églises
enfin des lavoirs donc des sites que je
vais dire un peu classique et ce site
qui est un peu original à mon avis a
certainement ses chances d'être
sélectionné à la rentrée le site devrait
donc être flambant neuf un lifting idéal
pour pour faire décoller son activité
[Musique]
voilà ça n'est pas une chapelle ça n'est
pas un château libé d'elle un hangar de
type eiffel c'est aussi notre patrimoine
c'est splendide ça vous plaît tout à
fait et donc ses sélectionnés forcément
fallait dire et ça va aider au
financement participatif puisque en plus
d'être à l'appel à projet de stéphane
bern ça va encourager le mécénat
participatif autour de ces deux hangars
qui sont sensationnelles et qu'il faut
garder patrick giraudeau vous battez
pour un château renaissance et là vous
voyez un hangar ça vous fait pas bizarre
que d'être sélectionné en même temps
qu'eux car en gare je partage tout à
fait l'analyse tome se bidonne le
pentagone il ne s'arrête pas au début du
20e siècle voire même au début du 21e il
y aura peut-être du patrimoine
certainement d' aller à
montceau-les-mines la restauration de la
traction titine enfin d'accord
merveilleux patrimoine écrit comment
vous avez accueilli les uns les autres
vous qui vous battez depuis longtemps
pour le patrimoine l'idée d' emmanuel
macron de confiée à stéphane bern cette
mission sur le patronat est ce que vous
vous ai dit a enfin on va penser à nous
ou est ce que vous dites oui enfin c'est
un petit peu de la com c'est un peu de
l'affichage que stéphane bern d'une
personnalité publique
je vais poser la question à corinne
molina et apatrides giraudeau avant de
la poser à guidel qui participent à
l'action de cette mission
corinne molina parce que vous en avez
pensé honnêtement moi j'espère que que
cette mise en lumière en tous les cas
par monsieur berne
permettra effectivement d'avoir une
autre notion une autre approche du
patrimoine encore une fois je pense
qu'il n'y a pas que du patrimoine dit
majeur en france mais qui est aussi tout
ce petit patrimoine qui mérite qu'on s'y
intéresse et c'est ce qui a l'air de se
dessiner là pour l'instant hormis donc
pourvu que ça dure outre patrick
giraudeau vous vous êtes vous travaillé
à la restauration de ce château depuis
des années avec votre association
et là tout d'un coup un coup de
projecteur moi je parlais de notre
vision associative wind ou encore in a
parlé d'une vision un peu plus diffuse
nous on a dit kouf on va avoir peut-être
une aide conséquente c'est pas vrai là
on attend de voir les résultats du loto
du patrimoine le 14 septembre contre eux
mettrait ib d'elle c'est une bonne
opération excellent moteur mais ne faut
pas que l'arbre cache la forêt c'est ça
parce que voilà comment on fait pour
choisir 205 et je crois qu'il y en avait
deux ans lisa un sens de proposer mais
derrière les 2500 il y en a peut-être
beaucoup plus donc si vous voulez c'est
pour ça que c'est un excellent moteur
mais derrière il faut faire en sorte que
tous les autres qui oeuvrent pour des
édifices ou une auto des choses modestes
puissent être accompagnés
donc je crois qu'il faut que cet élan
soit des x vous vous battez pour
préserver le patrimoine
une des missions confiées par emmanuel
macron à stéphane bern c'est aussi de
trouver de nouveaux chemins pour le
financement de ces restaurations cette
préservation du patrimoine
est-ce que vous par exemple vous auriez
des idées à lui souffler comment est-ce
qu'on peut financer ce patrimoine
parce que ça il faut que ça dure dans le
temps un corinne molina afrique 02 je
souhaite que le loto du patrimoine de
2018 soit reconduit tous les ans
pourquoi tant le téléthon existe depuis
des dizaines d'années la télé principal
effet un loto du patrimoine qui serait
reconduit d'année en année je vais
rester avoue corinne molina parce que
vous vous faites appel aussi à des
jeunes pour pour des actions sur des
chantiers concrets à du bénévolat comme
les associations
donc c'est une autre forme d'engagement
il n'y a pas que l'argent
finalement c'est vrai que sur l'aspect
financier nous travaillons main dans la
main avec la fondation du patrimoine
grâce à la fondation ont fait appel au
mécénat privé ont fait appel au mécénat
d'entreprise
après effectivement si monsieur berne a
d'autres idées pour permettre un nouveau
associations de générer de l'argent
privé
ben moi je le prends son idée peu mieux
son idée c'est par exemple de faire
payer l'entrée des églises c'est une
bonne idée de lui --de elle selon vous
enfin c'est quelque chose qu'il a lancée
il a pas dit qu'il fallait le faire
c'est une idée parmi d'autres il faut
que ce soit participatif en termes
d'approbations voilà et puis les
entreprises ou si je pense il faut
vendre l'attractivité
il faut vendre les aspects économiques
du patrimoine est pas resté au niveau
vieux cailloux corps met en place mais
vraiment dire que c'est un vecteur de
futur et c'est pour ça aussi que les
technologies modernes associé au
patrimoine doivent être des solutions
pour tirer l'attractivité l'économie
donc ça veut dire dans le numérique
notamment pour complètement notamment
pour trouve tout l'aspect visite c'est
ça que vous entendez oui visiter
connaissance du patrimoine exactement
raconter une histoire en trois
dimensions on travaille au niveau de
vézelay actuellement on pourrait très
bien imaginer l'histoire de vésinne en
trois dimensions aller à cluny vous
verrez déjà dans prototype si je puis
dire même une très belle application
bon on arrive aussi avec des robots en
trois dimensions à refaire des statuts
des choses comme ça donc je crois que le
patrimoine aussi c'est pas un vieux truc
c'est quelque chose qui est tourné vers
le futur et qui est tourné vers
l'économie de pays ont 89 millions de
visiteurs par an en france soit 10 de
touristes qui viennent pour notre
patrimoine et pas simplement pour la
tour eiffel ou l'arc de triomphe tout à
fait qu'on peut en attirer aussi chez
nous pour visiter g que comprendre que
les visites de chinois par exemple en
côte d'or c'était peut-être pour les
vins mais c'est aussi pour le patrimoine
que nous avons il en profite aussi pour
visiter effectivement de belles choses
comme le château de rochefort entre
autres les forges de buffon l histoire
merci à tous les trois d'avoir accepté
de participer à cette émission on verra
ce que donnera effectivement sur l'auto
c'est le 14 septembre prochain qui est
organisée ce loto du patrimoine c'est un
tirage supplémentaire à stéphane bern le
dit souvent mais c'est important pan
d'argent à personne dans cette histoire
d'un tirage supplémentaire et c'est la
part de l'état qui il rappelait aussi un
jeu de grattage on va le dire puisque le
château de bussy-rabutin et sera parmi
les effigies de ce jeu de grattage qui
sera lancée à l'occasion aussi des
journées européennes du patrimoine
rendez vous en septembre prochain pour
faire le point merci donc d'avoir
accepté de répondre à ces questions et à
vous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant un point sur l'actualité
régionale avec arnaud lefebvre suivi de
l'édition nationale présentée par
catherine matausch très bon dimanche à
tous sur france 3
[Musique]